he must be like this guy is never gonna
last eight years and for sure he's gonna
win again I'm gonna be the president
so you think for sure he wins again
because is that because whoever the
Democrats decide to put in he's gonna be
an equal turd sandwich again you're a
super smart dude
but you're also a brute your big giant
savage [ __ ] right so how many
people have underestimated you because
you're a big giant Savage [ __ ]
plenty talk stupid to you and acted like
you were a [ __ ] I'd say equal street
fights two fights in the UFC yeah
there's a lot of people right the and
just people in general like they'll get
snotty um take stevia tree I'm good my
men but I think there's a certain part
of us that might be doing that with him
I don't think he is I think he's really
good at winning this is this is not a
nut like up an endorsement of him no
caveats necessary I'm horrified by this
immigration policy of separating
children from their parents I think
that's subhuman his wife came out and
said that was [ __ ] yeah his wife's
an immigrant bro his wife barely speaks
English it's chaos right it's crazy I
hate I hate all that stuff these are
just families they're just people who
love each other you got to keep them
together if they break the law you keep
them together get them out of here if
you want I mean if you want to send them
back to where they came from if you're
you're hell-bent on that but taking them
from their kids is subhuman I mean it's
beyond it's not us it's not what we're
doing in 2018 that aside all that aside
he's probably kind of [ __ ] win again
man I think he's probably gonna win
again I think he he gets in these
confrontations with people and they
think he's a dolt I don't think he's a
dolt
I think he's there's no way to be as
successful he's been I know he's heads
ups and downs and [ __ ] like that
but like
what he just just the way he was able to
dismantle all those guys in those
Republican debate City torment [ __ ]
turn part on the part dad no business
they had no business doing that with him
they just were too emotionally tied up
in his responses there was so much
negativity and energy it was like is all
this anxiety like a fight where a guy's
in full panic you know you seeing like
street fights especially guys just go
into full panic or even just talking
[ __ ] in the schoolyard you know like
yeah one guys getting bullied bullies
got the crowd watching them and the
other guys like will butBut you'reyou're
[ __ ] you man your owner is like oh that
ain't gonna work you know that's kind of
that's what the rest looked like Ted
Cruz that's what they all looked like
he's just been doing this his whole life
he's been talking [ __ ] his whole life
you know and he's got a lot of [ __ ]
supporters and if the economy keeps
doing good man it's gonna be a hard sell
to put some guy in there like Bernie
Sanders who you know all the right-wing
people fake just wants to give away all
your money give away all your money to
welfare brats even the left was
protecting against that Yeah right
cuz there's still money on the left I
should point out I know jack [ __ ] about
politics this is very important to point
out anybody that ever says you shouldn't
be talking about politics that's crazy
because anybody should be able to talk
about whatever they want but what I
shouldn't do is give anybody the
impression that I know what I'm talking
about
cuz I definitely don't like if you had
to get me to explain to you how Congress
and the Senate works and how long the
terms are and what's what's the cattle
you know what what they have to do
that'd be a sloppy ass [ __ ]
conversation alright I'm no political
expert you know like Mike Pence is no
MMA expert you know I mean like he
probably could tell you Conor McGregor
is you know like that's probably like we
have equal knowledge and government yeah
but still you might win just in terms of
like generally good yeah it's a game you
definitely could look what did what is
it it's a [ __ ] game it's a game it's
a very high stakes gigantic game where
you're trying to win a popularity
contest
he won what do you think of the rock
potentially becoming president when
that [ __ ] was that [ __ ] blew up and I
was like wait a minute now
if you look at the current state and it
is a popularity contest and we want
somebody who can literally rock the mic
has the gift of gab yeah but then you
also have somebody who's doing a
manatorian [ __ ] is as famous as [ __ ]
anyone has ever been highest-paid dude
in Hollywood he's so nice - yeah look at
that guy in your you don't you don't
question his character no he's right we
dart
yeah he's sweetheart you meet him in
real life he's like that - he's a big
[ __ ] big giant [ __ ] I
think he could do it he can win he can
win especially if he has Oprah's as VP
and I'm not even [ __ ] around not
saying it's a good idea folks not what
I'm saying I'm saying you don't think
that the rock and Oprah could win but
who would be the women would get super
pissed off if the rock was the President
and Oprah was VP Oprah would have to say
look she's potentially next in line
that's not a bad thing she's Mike Pence
nodding an approval but she wanted yeah
a lot of people would want her to be
President Oprah to be the first female
president to counter like the first
celebrity president being Trump Oprah
counters that with the first female
celebrity president see that's a big win
with the rock vvp in that situation it's
tough to get the rock to take a [ __ ]
bag see yeah the rock is he's the rock
it's tough to get him to take a back
seat it would be fascinating to see what
happens next
that's what's gonna be I mean how we're
gonna try to play this out how people
are gonna play this out the popularity
contest aspect of it because it's just
okay if it really devolves into that you
know it's like in here's it the other
thing how much of his regulations are
helping well and what and what do we do
now
it has really [ __ ] up maybe permanent
consequences to the earth that's true -
right but what what stuff have they
implemented other than I know they did
offshore drilling right that concerned a
lot of people
and it was explained better to me about
the the monuments and the private land
I've read a bunch of different and
publicly and rather I've read a bunch of
different takes on that and essentially
what they did is bring it back to where
it was before the Obama administration
changed it so it was it was listed a
certain way and then when the Obama
administration changed it they felt that
was an overstep I don't know why hmm and
it doesn't seem to be they haven't
started any like mineral drills or oil
drills or anything in these areas I
don't know what they're doing I don't
know I don't know if they're really just
trying to deregulate things more they
feel like the government overstepped
their boundaries or if they really have
nefarious ideas they're trying to like
figure out a way to get some oil out of
a Salmon River Hotel yeah man I mean